so nobody really saw Russia behaving in
the way that Russia has behaved in 2015
did they nobody expected them to
increase output particularly what does
that tell us about 2016 and what they
can do there well I think you're
absolutely right
analysts were forecasting Russian
production would fall this year not
because of any decision that would be
taken by the Russian government but
because the industry is very heavily
reliant on ageing fields in West Siberia
and it was felt that with low prices the
industry wouldn't be able to invest in
natural decline would take over it
hasn't happened we've had output growth
we've had new post-soviet records in
four months of this year and it's
noticeable that opinions for 2016 are
changing as recently as two months ago
the International Energy Agency was
forecasting Russian production would
fall by close to a hundred thousand
barrels a day last month it forecasts
that it would remain flat its latest
report two weeks ago forecast that
Russian output would grow in 2016 by
very small 20,000 barrels a day or so
but but it's a big change around Leino
market big players in the oil markets
trying to play for market share seem to
have been the big theme of 2015 and and
we see the glut that ensued as a result
do you think see anything that changes
that dynamic as we go into next year
well as a macro economist I suppose it's
striking to observe that for so long or
oil has been a supply-side structural
story but it is traded as a demand-side
market story through the policy reaction
function of course it is the
expectations that the continued weakness
in oil resulting from suppliers desire
for market share growth as you rightly
said combined worth that dollar strength
which is not least reinforced by the
factors that depress oil such as de
leveraging in emerging markets
oversupply in emerging markets in terms
of industrial capacity and of course the
continuous deflationary pressures we
have in the US on that are keeping the
ECB at the money pumping oprand so the
the the
weakness here is that or the worry is
that through the policy reaction
function in this week oil becomes its
own driver of deflation expectations and
of course global currency wars
expectations that in turns creates this
fear about dislocation of market pricing
way beyond oil so I'm worried about this
being a catalyst who brought a
dislocation does seem to permeate almost
every conversation we have Rama staff
carry me what's happening commodities
Julian when you look at what OPEC has
been doing would you say that then their
strategy of playing for market share has
failed when you see what Russia has been
doing in the US well I mean you know
it's certainly an easy argument to make
and that here we are more than a year on
prices down at 11 year lows that hardly
seems like success but I think one has
to look at what the alternative was and
particularly what the alternative was
for Saudi Arabia and the other Arab oil
producers and as they saw it their only
alternative was to cut production to
maintain prices which would have created
the environment to allow another big
year of growth in US production so they
would cut further and further and
further we have to remember that for the
last three years US output was growing
at over a million barrels a day now it's
flat